miles de edificios como este están aún
llenos de personas en su interior más de
un día después del terremoto de 7.8 el
sudeste de Turquía hace un día y medio
en la madrugada del domingo al lunes se
cuenta que hay más de 3.500 Muertos
tanto en el sur de Turquía como en el
norte sigue también muy afectado por ese
terremoto que se suma además de su
humanitarias
de guerra los habitantes de esta región
están completamente devastados muchos
hablan incluso de que barrios e incluso
actividades enteras han quedado o
completamente destruidas o casi para
derrumbarse del todo en los próximos
días incluso ahora mismo nos encontramos
muy afectada no la más porque un poco
unos kilómetros más al sur cerca de la
frontera está en la ciudad de antakya
según explican residentes que salen de
esa ciudad viniéndose aquí en dirección
al norte explican completamente